C'est payé par notre portefeuille. C'est
payée par l'argent du contribuable, vous
l'avez dit, et on est sur une campagne
de propagande de ce que sont les
idées développées depuis le début par le
président de la République. Et ce n'est pas
sain. On a vraiment l'impression que là,
on tord ce qui, normalement, doit être un
clip objectif, destiné à s'adresser aux
Français de tous bords. Et là, on voit
très bien le message subliminal.
Le message subliminal, c'est en gros : il
y a les gentils et les méchants,
levez-vous dimanche pour voter pour
les gentils. Vous avez le choix.
Cette fois-ci, vous avez le choix. Cette
élection, ce n'est pas une élection pour
éliminer, c'est une élection pour choisir.
Et je fais sur cette fin de campagne un
appel à tous les électeurs de la
droite et du centre, à tous les Français
qui partagent ces convictions : c'est le
moment de vous exprimer, c'est le moment de vous faire entendre.
La seule liste qui est capable de porter
cette voix, ces convictions de la droite
et du centre, c'est à dire ?
Un, on croit dans l'Europe.
Nous, on veut une Europe qui défend ses
frontières. On veut une Europe qui
défend les produits de ses
entreprises.
On veut une Europe qui affirme son
identité, notamment face à l'islamisme
Eh bien, on est la seule liste qui peut
envoyer des députés au Parlement
européen qui défendent ces convictions.
On a à faire dans cette élection un
choix sur l'Europe on veut. Au fond,
résumons-nous assez simplement :
vous avez
le choix entre le Rassemblement national,
c'est la déconstruction de l'Europe et
la déconstruction de l'euro. De l'autre
côté, vous avez le projet qui est porté
par Emmanuel Macron.
Toujours plus de taxes. Mais l'Europe
d'Emmanuel Macron, c'est aussi celle de
l'élargissement et là dessus il y a un
double discours total par rapport à sa
tête de liste. À Trieste, il a dit qu'il
souhaitait l'élargissement aux pays des
Balkans. L'Albanie doit normalement
ouvrir les négociations et ça a été
accepté. La France n'y a pas
opposé son veto.
Notre ligne est très simple : tous
nos députés s'opposeront à tout pas qui irait dans un élargissement supplémentaire et
on arrête les négociations avec la
Turquie parce que la Turquie n'est pas
européenne.
Pour nous, il y aura un avant et un après
cette élection parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on a réussi à faire ?
On a réussi à rajeunir. On a réussi à
faire émerger de nouveaux talents.
On a réussi à rassembler. Et on a réussi
à montrer que la droite se
reconstruisait en assumant ses valeurs
tout en fédérant. C'est évidemment pour
nous une étape très importante et c'est
une étape dans cette reconstruction. Et
je suis très lucide, on n'est pas arrivés
ce n'est pas fini,
les Français ne nous ont pas encore fait
confiance à nouveau. Ils ont ce doute que
vous avez d'ailleurs verbalisé en disant :
est-ce qu'ils ont tiré les leçons ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont changé ? Est-ce que
c'est vraiment une nouvelle droite ?
À nous d'être capables de répondre.